la star academy revient et s'installe
près de chez nous exit le château de
dammarie les lys
cette année les académiciens s'installe
sur la commune le château fort la venue
de cette émission de téléréalité en
vallée de chevreuse soulève bien des
questionnements pour répondre aux
riverains une réunion publique a été
organisée
je souhaitais que soit associé à cette
réunion et les gendarmes et les pompiers
de manière à ce que la population soit
rassurée sur les problèmes de
l'environnement et de sécurité publique
et vous voyez que les questions qui ont
été posées
justement été bien ciblée sur les accès
la sécurité d abord l'environnement ça
m'inquiétait déjà pour ce que j'ai dit à
cette réunion c'est à dire l'impact
visuel déjà avec la mise en place de
tentes d'algeco d'un parking mais plus
de 30 voitures voilà on se demande les
conséquences que pourrait avoir la
présence de la star ac' plus les impacts
en fait au niveau de la de la gêne du
quotidien le stationnement
éventuellement les débordements qui
pourraient avoir lieu sarah qui est un
événement quand même assez assez
important pour une petite commune comme
château fort génère la mise en place
déjà d'un partenariat très très étroit
entre la gendarmerie les pompiers et
bien sûr la production endemol les
risques potentiels ils sont pas
tellement du fait du nombre de personnes
qui pourraient venir sur le site mais
plutôt de paparazzi de curieux qui
pourrait voir rentrer à l'intérieur donc
du château la gendarmerie de magny les
hameaux se veut réactive en cas d'
alerte cinq minutes suffisent pour se
rendre au château de lageneste pendant
trois mois
des réservistes sur mobilisés et des
renforts assuré le courant groupement va
nous mettre à disposition des renforts
de gendarmes mobiles du peloton de
surveillance et d'intervention de
rambouillet et on peut aussi avoir des
renforts d'unités proches comme la
gendarmerie de chevreuse et la
gendarmerie des transports aériens
toussus-le-noble pas de psychose pour
autant après huit années d'émissions la
production endemol semble habituée aux
protocoles de sécurité
nous avons une société qui s'occupe de
la sécurité mais
voilà nous travaillons en échange avec
la gendarmerie
nous avons souhaité cette réunion avec
monsieur le maire bien avant l'été quand
on a choisi en fait le domaine et pour
nous c'était d'expliquer pourquoi on est
là expliquer pourquoi on l'a choisi
on ne va pas le château en fête de la
route voilà certain nombre de critères
qui faisait que notre choix a été porté
sur ce domaine le domaine de la geneste
que les académiciens taperont jeudi soir
après l'émission de lancement sur nrj 12
ils vont prendre possession en fait du
château auquel vont découvrir en fait et
bien évidemment leurs champs mais
surtout les salles de répétition des
salles de répétitions de danse la salle
de répétition soissons ceni qui sert à
ça ils vont s'approprier les lieux et
puis surtout découvrir le parc est
magnifique mais les élèves de la star
academy ne connaîtront de château fort
que le domaine de la geneste
interdiction formelle de sortir à
l'extérieur